hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
knock-knock now that music is quite
different I've got it it's really a case
of sleepwalking it makes perfect sense
that my probably hit that diary
somewhere myself in my sleep as a child
I hid things in many places now have to
go through them all if you say so
that music did indeed get much more
sinister did it not I'm almost positive
it did so anyway he said in the last
episode that we need to hurry through
this place we can't risk being caught by
the monsters they lurk in the darkness
because there's something waiting on the
other side I was wrong
they didn't come from inside they are
the real gets my mind tricked me I
should have imagined them as something
different but now it's too late is it
too late I don't think it's ever too
late man can still fix this so good time
right away you need to get out of here
because there's something on the other
side that we need to deal with I'm not
sure how much more to this game what
what who was that the camera like
focused up there something happened and
now someone is crying oh I didn't mean
to open that door but just as good
it's too good I guess oh this game still
gives me the creeps I don't care how
long I've been playing it what was that
that was a new noise alrighty
at least ah oh god I almost ran right
into you leave guys right there
nobody supposed to do about that okay
imagine up something good in here I
thought that already was something
imagined up in here like a hidey hole
come on man
oh good paintings those will do me lots
Oh where'd you come from I don't care I
want you anyway thank you so much buddy
hey look we're getting things maybe okay
that's way up there I don't even need to
worry about that that's way far away
okay but this is good right this is good
they're leaving guys that are blocking
my path right on the way down
nan Turan tan tan-tan oh good footprints
on the floor hi Tommy this is good right
is this good wait a minute this doesn't
seem like it should be happening ah gah
God heard that that is the squeaky
squeaky of a gurney but thankfully I
don't have to try very hard now you
don't know they know where are you know
where I am and why is someone still
crying uh you don't hear jack I'm not
the one crying little girl you strange
lady yeah I'm just waiting I'm just
waiting out the clock bye now this might
be the fastest I've oh I saw the gurney
he's all the way over there
hallucinations they're due to lack of
sleep I can't keep to catch up on sleep
due to my nightly rounds wait were you
about to imagine something get what
we're almost at time okay
oh crap the Gurney's are coming not the
Gurney's I got it
oh it did it did it did it did you okay
okay what do you imagine hey dawn
good god they were after my giblets
let's play a home on the edge now set
the table is this for a memorial for
each place layout sheets of paper
instead of dishes close your eyes and
draw circles on each piece of paper
repeating your mind two different voices
round round while imagining how large
the circles are sooner or later you will
hear a voice as clear as if someone sent
it in your own head squirrel square with
an exclamation Park or no not round then
walk out of the room and close the door
behind you okay that's good I like that
there's not many things left then it
just spirals off into darkness to the
door just with the door I don't know if
I go to the front door but there be
another note no oddly enough no hey
buddy
Hey are you still not worried about this
guy that seems to be kind of right there
are you knowing I'm just gonna go I'm
gonna go for the thing first I don't
even know if I have to go through the
whole house IRA I really don't I have no
idea I don't even know if I'm playing
this game correctly because this game
has left me in a mystery and it's good
to come to the end of your road with
your heart at peace
it would be most grievous to beat one's
face without having wrap things up ah
what does that mean you crazy guy no
good the door has opened
well let's go then imagining I need to
find the girl again
before it's too late need to find the
girl watch out for the thing is I'm
going left I see you bastards you leave
he bastards and I see you in the wood
back there you ain't gonna get me oh I
see you I old yet the booty out the fire
yet go get me for damn sure
okay I don't know where the house is
there she is she's right there right
there okay you got a ton at the house
it's right there gonna last I gotcha
Hey look at that I got an achievement
good things come in threes that's good
right that's good that is a big house
that is a really big house I gotta say
that that house is big pretty big gotta
imagine pretty big so what does it mean
does it just go on forever
keine maybe that's an analogy for the
house if this guy is in okay that's the
end of the sequence and the house that I
saw Oh
don't dick with me the house was right
there house was right there come on
why'd you have to move it yep oh oh you
didn't move it well you didn't move that
far anyway yes this is going much better
than last one I'm like sipping through
this oh look more things what does it
mean why are they creating more houses
after the monster has shown up and I'm
back here let's see if I can get through
this one just as quickly probably not
what do you have to say for yourself I
have nightmares constantly the same
dream haunts me every night well I miss
that ah damn it okay so that's the edge
of the house I don't know what that said
I don't even know if you could guys can
pause that and see that I went by way
too quickly
voodoo all right I still don't know what
the deal is with the crack at the top of
the screen oh really is that how it's
going to be okay down we go okay that
was actually just a coincidence I the
lightning struck and I zoomed out to see
how that lit house is laid out but
anyway yeah you I don't need to explain
myself to you guys I got this all unlock
all right things are going by pretty
quickly there's not much left over here
so I'm just gonna light these rooms and
then go back to the other way oh good
the crying has begun again with light
this broke I'm looking at all the lights
I don't see which light just broke
it's like oh I don't see a monster why
are you crying
I got him I think I really got to find
the source of the Krong king and he was
gonna imagine come on time yes oh come
on
here we go okay I got I need to find the
source of the crying so I'm gonna use
this time and then I'm gonna try to
avoid or save any of the other ones
until I find it
there's no directionality to the crying
anyway so I can't even tell where it's
coming from I don't even know what I'm
doing it hello oh good that's way over
there and kind of secluded hurry up man
imagine up your crazy dream world sorry
no one's home need to find the crying
girl
why are you crying I'm gonna hold off on
that what do you want me to be still are
you in here are you in here oh god don't
do what don't do what don't know what
you want from me little girl
be still for what wait that's our you
haven't forgotten me yet do I at least
appear in your dream sometimes I saw
something something was kneeling like
turning his face away I gotta get to it
I don't know how to get to it I got a
hit to it my god oh Jesus balls the
ghosty goo oh it got me it just sent me
back I don't have time to waste but I
saw the crying someone in here right
there right there behind this door
oh god damn it all right you know what
my times already down if I hit up 100 ah
god damn it why did I let him get me why
did I let him get me I was right there
damn it okay you know what I'm not even
gonna do the things in the room I'm just
gonna find the girl cuz I think that's
important at first I thought I was sick
but that's not the case I'm totally
normal
oh yeah about as normal as mom is pretty
normal but but you should shut up
just angina okay so is it the same house
is it the same house is it the same
house will I be wandering around in the
darkness for all my days why have I
cursed myself with this okay I want to
go through there that's a bad idea
something was a shakin a shimmy Ananda
shakin anything in here
anything you want to tell me bro
anything you want to show me Oh boring
but um some I'm opening it anyway
screw you can't stop me but whose key oh
oh no what happened
Oh No Oh No
ah god damn it oh no I went into some
weird world there's a bunch of doors I
know this is why I was before wait is my
is my bar at the top of the screen going
is it ah god damn it I can't even Sam I
don't even know you got a maybe I can
find something in here damn it
again oh wait I can see you Mike I'm
getting cracks around I gotta go in the
door I gotta go into more these damn it
again again okay how about this one
there we go
good enough
and fines back goddamnit
Feist I can't do anything right can't
find the crying girl anymore I guess I
gotta keep turning on lights and
accelerating time until I hear her
crying and then I can find her maybe now
I'm definitely awake time from nine
nightly rounds I need to go through the
house to make sure everything in this
rightful place okay so he doesn't know
if he's awake or not I'm so confused
because he doesn't know what he's doing
that's I am so utterly confused I heard
something in the darkness Hey quiet now
Hey look time that's good
really quiet now I'm kind of curious as
to why because before there was music
playing you know sinister music okay
right what are you imagining now with
your crazy messed up mind huh here
there's not much room there to the right
and I don't see anything I can't quite
tell I don't know if that you know I'll
go down here here I think I hear
something to them okay don't go in that
door that's a bad idea don't know though
no no no no I don't think I see her over
there Oh what happened what just
happened what Wimbley monster whim booze
his way over to Wimbledon town he's
gotta find her just gotta find her damn
it I was so close before
dead end no snow I can't see cuz of that
glare on my screen
need to turn on a light guy God hey wait
what I got an achievement that said
babysitter and where is it buried
somewhere close by when I came home
there was only dirt on the bed and also
leaves arranged in a peculiar way hey
that was from the note that was what
that guy wrote his dad I think it was
his dad anyway okay that's far away I'm
not worried about that but you
interrupted my lamp
resetting you dick you son of okay
imagine something good I need okay no I
don't need to go that way I changed my
mind very considerably I changed my mind
come on give me some good give you gotta
give it gabagool keep it GABA give me
some time give me some time to think the
day where you are why I'm not moving I
trust you I'm trusting you on this one
boo-hoo-hoo-hoo that was the first time
something you said actually made damn
sense what do I do
oh good oh wow what happened where am I
now
alright what the dick what the tense I
got kicked out of the room
oh oh oh don't goof I done goofed
ah
is it bedding there's a bed place to
hide here oh let me just reset this
maybe I'll get a time thingy
we do to me
alright you know what go this way it
doesn't want me to go that way
apparently do this really why I don't
know what she's telling me I don't know
what I don't know what's right and
what's wrong
I guess I didn't get anything good about
that maybe I should have listened to her
give me time you hummed hide and seek
it's not just a game it's a way of life
no matter where or how you hide time
will always run backwards Biak who has
be aku has why why do I need to get
outside your home what does abide what
do you mean are you trying to tell me
lady oh oh what's it happened it's what
I'm a fact okay no need I trust you I
trust you I trust you on this one oh
Justin
maybe there is a need I'm gonna see if I
can get a time thingy out of this if not
I'm gonna obey her n come on I did it
I saw that ah goddamn it
fudge nutters Oh balls okay well you
want from me give me a time this one's
hard
good what good does that Oh candles what
is that that's strange
okay I'm getting out of here it's taking
too long I gotta go I gotta get away oh
it's pretty scary I got it a bit it's
pretty freaky if I was living in this
place I'd be concerned I'd be a little
concerned I get a time thingy can I get
a time thingy
just when you thought about you really
need to wake up this that all will end
this I want to wake up I want the dawn
on the flip-flapping dawn I haven't
imagined up a time in a while it seems
like this last few hours have been going
the same place forever they haven't
moved it's just me here's a clock of
course its lone down a lot it might just
be me but it feels like these last few
hours have dragged on forever no no need
okay I believe you
oh crap this is a dead end
Hey Wow oh okay just let me use the time
I'm so close so close
eggnog ding-dong yes goddamn so why
isn't the giant monster here which one's
a real world which one is not aah
we are now playing resentment
resettlement it's a wishful making game
this is how you need to play it if
someone manages to wake up one hour
before dawn that person should declare
themselves the living in their thoughts
at sunrise the living should stand
before the closed door and say out loud
the hour is at hand it's time to get
ready to go after these words the door
should stay closed if it doesn't work
that person is no longer the living okay
weirdo whoa wait a minute whoa I jumped
ahead a bit I jumped ahead where's the
rain I don't know what it means but I'm
all out of time for this one so thank
you all so much for watching click be in
the Dacians for more videos that i've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
the new bucket
the red button red one
you might survive really
bud
Oh
oh there